yeah i mean kj rate's the guy who may be
leaving via free agency so yeah he will
be there as long as you okay jay i i
miles i want to run my theory by you you
don't have to agree with me
trust me there will be no employment
consequences if you disagree with me
i look at it in a very simple way no i'm
certain no and i mean
i do mean that i didn't mean how are you
i do mean
speak freely on any topic that you want
i
i wouldn't you can rid me of this
meddlesome priest
you can you can try no no you can't well
done
you can do your research talk to anybody
who's ever worked with us at pft
except for one or two i am all right
now um i haven't even started drinking
yet
uh russell wilson here's my theory
when well yeah it's uh i i will be
within the next 45 minutes but at least
not right now
me too when i read the story in the
athletic yesterday
and i got to the end of it and and i i
really do believe
anyone who can prove that they read
every word of one of these hashtag
long read articles should get a free
t-shirt
i did read it all and when i got to the
end i
said look this is simple if the seahawks
don't view russell wilson the way that
russell wilson
views russell wilson trade him to a team
that does
because that team is going to give you
an offer that's going to make you
say they're idiots for offering that
much well
they're going to treat russell wilson
like patrick mahomes that's why they're
offering that much
so to me this is a no-brainer you either
are going to treat this guy
like he wants to be treated and regarded
and have the offense run through him
are you going to take the best offer
from someone
who will treat him that way who who will
listen to his ideas on how to improve
the offense and who will have the
offense
run through him whether it works or not
different issue for now
russ clearly wants to be somewhere where
he's going to get that same
treatment that we've seen with patrick
mahomes where
you're the offense and you're the guy
that stirs this drink
yeah okay well first of all i also did
read uh to the end of the athletic story
so
if they're giving away athletic t-shirts
or hats i don't know i guess i'll take
one
but i think the biggest thing that i
also came away with from that was that
if the seahawks
really do think that russell wilson
can't be
that guy that elevates um that elevates
the offense to a level
where he is a top three qb right and
that seems to be the way that russell
wilson sees himself
like i guess this is a roundabout way of
me saying that yeah i agree with you
that they
should be able to trade him because look
somebody's going to give them
three first-round picks for russell
wilson and maybe something else right
i would do that if that's the way i see
russell wilson as somebody who is an
elite quarterback
yes i give away three first-round picks
immediately because
those guys don't grow on trees and the
simple fact of the matter is if you do
give away three
round picks and you think russell wilson
is going to elevate you that much
then that means you're going to be in
the postseason probably every single
year
and those first round picks are going to
be i don't know maybe 20 at best
to 32 in theory and at that point a lot
of
a lot of football people out of gm's are
saying well you know those are basically
second round picks anyway because you're
kind of past that
really elite talent that comes at the
top of the first round
and if you have a good enough scouting
department then in rounds two through
seven
you should be able to pick up guys who
are still going to be able to help you
and make sure that you have the support
around the qb that you need
and the type of defense that you would
need in order to still win ball games so
yes if the seahawks really don't view
russell wilson as this elite guy
then yeah they probably should trade him
because like you said they're gonna get
a king's ransom back
here's bottom line they've had russell
wilson since 2012 they haven't been past
the division around since 2014.
so it's not like they're breaking up a
juggernaut franchise here and
and uh everyone's got a price i used to
think russell wilson was untouchable i
don't believe that he is because the one
thing we're not hearing
from anyone is there's no way in hell
that the seahawks will entertain trading
him
that clumsy message we're getting from
the texans is not
coming from the seahawks they're going
to listen
they may not say yes but they're going
to listen because they know miles it's
inevitable if it doesn't happen this
year
it's happening next year if it doesn't
happen next year it's happening the year
after
it is inevitable and pete carroll
presumably at some point after dealing
with this push and pull
for a certain period of time throws his
hands in the air and says i'm getting
too old for this
stuff right and and he is
i i i hope to still be working full-time
and vibrant and bouncing around before a
football game like he does pushing 70.
but at a certain point you just say
enough's enough god didn't want to be
here why are we going through this
charade
i don't want to be here well let's go
let's get what we can let's go we want
the guys who want to be here
and i can see carol kind of working
himself into that mindset once he
recognizes it's inevitable
well the other thing too i mean you just
mentioned they haven't been past the
division round since 14.
when they were doing that when they were
getting past the division around
the offense was different right it was
really really predicated on the run game
and we've heard pete carroll say that he
wants to get back to that and that's why
they've hired shane waldron from lorenz
they think that they can import some of
that stuff
that the rams have been doing on the
ground and winning games there
so if that's the case then who's to say
that
maybe the seahawks couldn't go get
another young quarterback
somebody that they can groom and mold
and shape in whatever way they want
and still win games if their offense is
running the ball the way that they used
to back when the legion of boom
was in its full bloom and they were
winning games primarily with defense but
also they were controlling the ball and
everything and i i think
russell wilson is good enough that they
don't have to play that way
but i mean in that athletic article what
they were talking about was look when
they really started unleashing russell
wilson and letting russ
cook and all that then there were games
where he started turning the ball over
and when he's turning the ball over like
that and you are losing games because
you're not controlling the game
then that's really gonna uh take pete
carroll off right and so
at that point yeah i think he might be
feeling like i'm getting too old for
this i know how i want to win ball games
here in seattle
i know it because we've done it before
and you know maybe they just say look if
somebody's gonna give us this king's
ransom then let's go and do it mike
yeah so the four teams for which russell
wilson
is willing to waive his no-trade clause
courtesy of his agent mark rogers who
stunningly went on the record and said
russell doesn't want to be traded he
wants to play for the seahawks but
but here are the four teams you play for
the raiders the cowboys the bears and
the saints
which one if any of them stands out to
you as the team that could get this done
if they really want to get it done the
raiders
and it's because they have a quarterback
that they can send back
who is already a starter he's already
established and i don't think
derek carr is bad quarterback i really
don't but i think he's above average
and if john gruden mike mayok think that
russell wilson is an elite quarterback
then that's why you make the move i
think look if if russell wilson is the
guy you think you're missing for your
offense to unlock what it could be
especially in the red zone
where they've had problems over the last
couple years and it's why they
are up there a lot of time in yards but
points they just
don't score enough of them then if he's
the difference in the red zone then yeah
maybe you go do it but those other teams
i mean the cowboys you have to send back
dak
and honestly i think that that could be
on a trajectory to be at least as good
as russell wilson if not better we'll
have to see how he is after
uh the injury the bears what are they
going to give you i mean except for
draft picks that are probably going to
be mediocre
and then the saints i mean they're also
a very good team but they don't
necessarily have something to give back
to you unless
maybe they were to sign jameis winston
and then they ship you him but
i would maybe rather have derrick carr
than jameis winston and i can i can't
believe
that's coming out of my mouth but if
you're pete carroll and you want to take
care of the football
then that i think would be a little bit
more appealing mike the bears could do
the old henny youngman take my wife
please line with nick foles he's under
contract other than that
there's no quarterback they can give
them one thing about dak prescott
i think it's impossible for the cowboys
to send dak prescott to the seahawks
because
they'd have to apply the franchise tag
again they'd have to get him to sign it
and then they'd be trading a contract
one year
37.68 million with the knowledge
that next year the only way to keep him
around against his will
franchise tag 54.25 million so i think
prescott just walks away as a free agent
and the cowboys get a compensatory draft
pick next year maybe they agree to give
whatever compensatory pick they get for
dak prescott
to the seahawks is part of this deal but
the other side of this too
because i i i agree if it's the raiders
send eric carr if it's the saints sente
some hill
i'd be intrigued by taysom hill if i was
the seahawks given the kind of offense
pete carroll
wants to run because now you got a guy
who will run the ball and you got a guy
who can throw some explosive passes down
the field if the running game is
softening up the defense
but but i don't want to get tied to this
notion i've seen some people point this
out
that they'll only do a deal if as part
of the deal they're getting a
quarterback
who they can plug you can find other
quarter you don't have to
you can't you don't have to say we're
only doing a trade for russell wilson
with a team that can guarantee us a
suitable
quarterback you can do a three-team deal
you can cut a deal with another team
they're capable of spinning multiple
plates if they want to get this done
the only problem is where do you go what
do you do
and none of these teams for whom russell
wilson
is willing to play are high enough on
the draft order that that would be a
solution you know if it's the jets hey
it's perfect perfect
get the second overall pick get a
quarterback get a second overall pick
and sam don't get a left tackle and get
a quarterback there's
all sorts of different things you can do
that's the fly in this particular
ointment for me miles
the idea that none of these teams is in
position
to give the seahawks the kind of first
first-round pick
that lets them address the quarterback
issue with one of the better guys in
this year's draft class
and the idea of maybe getting lucky with
russell wilson in round three several
spots after a punter was drafted
that's not going to strike twice in the
same lifetime
yeah probably not that's also not the
question you asked me so if i had known
that i could make three team deals then
i maybe would have said something like
that
because if i'm the jaguars right that
that's intriguing to me
maybe i would rather have russell wilson
than trevor lawrence no i don't know
that urban mind but he doesn't want the
jaguars but he doesn't want
but he doesn't want the jaguars that's
the problem right so then
you involve the jaguars with say the
raiders right
and then maybe the raiders will send
derrick carr
there and maybe jack something that's
intriguing yeah
or derek carter derek carr to carolina
and the eighth overall pick goes to
seattle right the the panthers clearly
looking
for an upgrade and i don't want to go
too far down the rabbit hole
but i had seen some scattered musings
this week that the raiders are thinking
about
extending derek carr's i wonder if
at some level that's just part of an
effort to boost the perception of derek
carr
to the extent that he will be traded to
the seahawks as part of a russell wilson
package or
to someone else to raise better funds
better draft pick
funds that would go to seattle because
that was just this weird random thing
that came up for no reason at all
because clearly if russell wilson falls
into their laps
they're going to say see you later derek
carr this is russell wilson
yes exactly and it was interesting
seeing some of the reporting out of
las vegas and saying like nah cool off
on that because
i mean at this point if you're the
raiders why exactly do you need to
extend derek carr i don't necessarily
know
that you do so i think the other thing
you kind of start seeing too out of las
vegas is
some reporters are saying hey this guy
is a top 10 qb
you know he's playing like a top 10 qb
and
i mean maybe you know i don't know that
i would say that i think that there's
kind of an easy list to make of 10
quarterbacks that you would take
before you would take derek carr and
again i don't think derek is a bad
quarterback but i think he's probably
just above average right
so even if the stats maybe say oh there
are cars this top 10 guy
i i just i'm not buying it sorry so
yeah but i think that might be another
one of those things to maybe boost the
perception of it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports